for my latest caption contest video i
selected this photo of our two dogs
unfortunately long since passed away
magnus and amica who my wife had raised
from puppies rescued in one case from
abuse in the other case from hurricane
katrina and they were pretty inseparable
i used to walk them everywhere once we
got to milwaukee
and they were in pretty good shape back
then and one of the things that they
discovered we we had a farmer's market
in our nearby park
and there was always a guy there
who would make kettle corn and a good
bit of kettle corn would end up falling
on the ground and being left there so
when they packed up and we would walk in
the park it was first magnus who
discovered that the kettle corn was
there he already liked popcorn and
kettle corn is even tastier in some
respects it's sweeter it's got more
crunch and amiki used to just look at
him eating it like he was crazy and then
she joined in and found that she really
liked it as well and so you've got this
picture here of them side by side on a
summer afternoon
eating up the abandoned kettle corn and
they pretty much would eat as much as
they could pack into their stomachs they
like this stuff so much so we got a
bunch of different captions for this the
first one is rather punny of course
corn dogs a lot of potential there you
know they're eating up corn it's kind of
corny
and so that's
we don't have to overthink that one too
much because we're gonna get a lot of
thinking perhaps a little bit of
overthinking as we move
to the next ones so here's the next one
referencing the kind of relativism about
perceptual qualities by convention sweet
and by convention salty by convention
hot by convention tasty but in reality
caramel and corn so you know referencing
some pre-socratic philosophy and some
relativism about perspective and
thinking about the metaphysics of it
here's another one a direct reference to
friedrich nietzsche who actually wrote
this my genius resides in my nostrils
and you know if we're going to say well
whose genius resides in their nostrils
if anyone it would be dogs wouldn't it
so
they
know well enough to eat up the corn
that's on the ground get something for
free and that's what they're doing
then we have a hegel reference here a
dog being recognized in and for itself
by a dog that's recognized in and for
itself in so far as they are two dogs
eating kettle corn
and you know what's the the reference
there well you know the the dialectic of
self-consciousness is about recognition
and
uh these two are recognizing each other
in some shared activity
um hegel doesn't really think
recognition is for animals but
that's okay this is a good one here we
have another hegel reference me and the
boys chowing down on the newest
contemporary hegelians book a bit of a
stretch you know i suppose you could say
that uh
hegelians work like that of hegel could
be considered just a heap of stuff in
which case you know if it's tasty enough
then you
mow down on it that doesn't really say
anything great about hegel of course
then we get uh two descartes references
and i suppose i should have seen these
coming first i snack therefore i am
and then uh i eat i exist and you notice
that one doesn't have a therefore
descartes original formulation of i
think
therefore i exist um
sometimes does sometimes doesn't have
the therefore right but there's a
connection between two different types
of things and this is kind of worth
dwelling on right snacking eating
uh is that part of our existence is that
how we know that we exist maybe not for
us human beings but perhaps that is so
absolutely central in the
life of an animal like a dog
the next one is a reference to a
scripture quote right this is something
that is at least at the very start
something said by
jesus and it's man shall not live on
bread alone but dogs do quite well on
corn apparently so
a little bit of twist there
and then we have another interesting
taking a
passage originally said by john kennedy
in this case
ask not what you can do for your owner
ask what your owner can do for you so
there's a transformation from country
to owner
and it's uh you know rephrasing what
your country or what your your owner the
person in charge is going to provide you
as far as benefits and then finally
wrapping it up we have this interesting
reference to i think it's pronounced
choran if you find yourself dealing with
existential dread after reading some
emil choran 10 out of 10 doctors
recommend a relaxing walk with a couple
of dogs along a trail ask your local
provider and animal shelter for more
details and you know actually that's
kind of a good bit of advice
i don't really suggest getting an animal
just to deal with your feelings of
existential dread but you know it is a
great thing to adopt pets as my
wife did with all of hers and actually
now that i think about it
more or less all the pets i've had have
been rescues as well
and um
yeah i mean pets are kind of handy for
giving you a
center and point to life you got to take
care of them they provide you with some
affection there's you know depending on
the kind of pet a relationship that
builds and so
i i guess it could be helpful with
existential dread so there you have it
those are the latest captions
if you want to get in on these
for the future you you probably want to
turn on your your notifications
and check the community tab on my
youtube channel we'll definitely be
doing more of these in the future so if
you'd like to get in on coming up with
some clever quips and maybe see yours
featured here in the next videos that's
exactly what you want to do
you